like a Bond villains lair built into a
mountain the Davos intercontinental
caters for high net-worth individuals
known as the golden egg the likes of
John Kerry Richard Branson and Bono all
stayed here last year every January it's
surrounded by barbed wire and guarded by
Swiss soldiers but it may not be enough
to protect it from bankruptcy so where
did it all go wrong
other than the week of the World
Economic Forum the 216 room hotel
struggles to fill its beds hard to
believe it could fail even the local
authority deferred a two hundred and
seventy thousand dollar planning fee
without a bank guarantee one of just a
few five-star hotels in the resort
Credit Suisse pump two hundred and fifty
two million dollars into the site the
hotel has since lost six percent of
value these holders stilly Park
announced bankruptcy and proceedings are
ongoing
while the intercom is once again fully
booked for the week of the forum the
problems facing Credit Suisse may deter
are the high-end hoteliers from setting
up in Davos